This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. A plane goes down somewhere in the Pacific. The survivors, stranded on a deserted island, are a group of schoolboys. At first, they celebrate their newfound escape from adult supervision, playing on the beach. Then they organize. They elect one of the boys, Ralph, as their chief. Ralph and several others get a fire going. But soon the boys begin resisting Ralph's efforts to lead them.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。一架飞机在太平洋某处坠毁。幸存者是一群被困在荒岛上的男学生。起初，他们为终于摆脱了成年人的管束而庆祝，在海滩上玩耍。接着他们组织了起来。他们选举了一个名叫拉尔夫的男孩担任首领。拉尔夫和其他几个人生起了火。但很快，男孩们就开始抗拒拉尔夫领导他们的努力。
The boys assigned to watch over the fire get distracted, and the fire goes out. They become paranoid and stoke each other's fears of a beast they're convinced is stalking the island. They split into warring factions and begin attacking one another. Three of them die. This is the story told in the 1954 novel, Lord of the Flies. It was written by an English school teacher named William Golding, and it reflected his harsh view of humans in general, and children in
负责看管火堆的男孩们分心了，火熄灭了。他们变得多疑，互相煽动对一个他们坚信正在岛上徘徊的野兽的恐惧。他们分裂成相互交战的派系，开始互相攻击。其中三人死亡。这就是1954年出版的小说《蝇王》中所讲述的故事。它由一位名叫威廉·戈尔丁的英国中学教师所写，反映了他对整个人类尤其是儿童的严酷看法。
particular. The novel ends when a British naval officer lands on the island and finds the children in a ragged, feral state. The novel entered the cultural consciousness as a warning. Without rules, systems, and adult supervision, children left alone would descend into chaos. As with many generalizations, there is some truth to this. A multitude of studies suggest kids thrive when they have stability. Chaotic and unpredictable environments can bring out the worst in us.
小说以一名英国海军军官登陆荒岛、发现孩子们衣衫褴褛、处于野蛮状态而结束。这部小说作为一个警告进入了大众的文化意识。如果没有规则、系统和成年人的管束，独处一隅的孩子们就会陷入混乱。正如许多概括一样，这其中包含着一些真理。大量研究表明，当孩子们拥有稳定性时，他们就会茁壮成长。混乱且不可预测的环境会激发出我们人性中最丑陋的一面。
But today we explore whether many societies have taken William Golding's warning too much to heart. If some supervision of children is a good thing, lots of parents, teachers and school administrators seem to think more is always better. When more is less and less is more, this week on Hidden Brain. When you're first learning to swim, it's not a good idea to be pushed into very deep water. You could drown. But it's also not a very good idea to simply pushed into very deep water. You could drown. But it's also not a very good idea
但今天我们将探讨，许多社会是否对威廉·戈尔丁的警告过于铭记于心了。如果说对儿童的一些管束是一件好事，那么许多父母、老师和学校管理者似乎认为管束越多越好。当“多即是少”、“少即是多”时，本周的《隐藏的大脑》。当你刚开始学游泳时，被推到很深的水里并不是一个好主意。你可能会淹死。但仅仅在浅水区蹚水也不是一个好主意。你永远学不会游泳。
to simply waddle around in the shallow. You'll never learn to swim. If you're a parent or a teacher, you're constantly asking yourself how to balance risk and safety for the kids in your care. Tip too far in one direction and you can put children in danger. Go too far in one direction and you can put children in danger. Go too far in the other and you
如果你是一位父母或老师，你必须不断扪心自问，如何为你所照顾的孩子平衡风险与安全。朝一个方向倾斜得太远，你就会把孩子们置于危险之中。朝一个方向走得太远，你就会把孩子们置于危险之中。朝另一个方向走得太远，你就会
deprive kids of the joy and power of exploration. At Boston College, psychologist Peter Gray studies how the balance between exploration and safety has changed for many children and the effects this has on their minds. Peter Gray, welcome to Hidden Gray. I'm very happy to be here. Peter, you were once at a pop-up event where the organizers provided kids with various materials, including twigs and tree branches, old boards, hammers, nails. Paint me a picture of the scene and tell me what happened. Yeah, so there were two young children,
剥夺孩子们探索的乐趣和力量。在波士顿学院，心理学家彼得·格雷研究了探索与安全之间的平衡对许多儿童发生了怎样的变化，以及这对他们的思想产生了什么影响。彼得·格雷，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。我很高兴来到这里。彼得，你曾经参加过一个快闪活动，组织者为孩子们提供了各种材料，包括细枝和树枝、旧木板、锤子、钉子。请为我描绘一下当时的场景，并告诉我发生了什么。是的，当时有两个幼儿，
maybe around six years old, very happily taking a couple of some of the very narrow boards and laying them out on the grass and walking along them like they were walking on a tightrope and pretending that this was a very narrow bridge and there were crocodiles on either side. And it was a very imaginative game. They were clearly having a lot of fun. And the dad, I assume it was the dad, at least of one of the two, came over and said,
大约六岁左右，非常高兴地拿了几块非常窄的木板，把它们铺在草地上，沿着它们走，就像走钢丝一样，假装这是一座非常窄的桥，两边都是鳄鱼。这是一个非常富有想象力的游戏。他们显然玩得很开心。然后爸爸——我假设那是爸爸，至少是其中一个孩子的爸爸——走了过来，说：
that's not what you're supposed to do with the boards. We're supposed to be building something with the boards. There's, see, there's hammer and nails here. And then he proceeded to take the boards and to start showing the children how to pound with hammer and nails. And what I observed is that children suddenly changed from really very happy and playful
这不是你们应该用木板做的事情。我们应该用木板建造东西。你看，这里有锤子和钉子。接着他开始拿起木板，向孩子们展示如何用锤子和钉子敲打。我观察到的是，孩子们突然从非常快乐和顽皮的状态，
to quite bored as they watched their father show them how to pound nails into boards. There was another time, Peter, when a sixth grade teacher told you about a game that her students had invented during the COVID pandemic. What was this game? She was feeling very bad for her sixth graders. They're still children, really, you know, they're 11 and 12 years old at most, and they're indoors all the school day. They don't have any recess at all. So she thought, well, wouldn't it be nice if I at least gave them a half an hour to play before school starts? Some of them
变得十分无聊，因为他们看着父亲向他们展示如何把钉子钉进木板里。彼得，还有一次，一位六年级老师跟你讲过一个游戏，是她的学生在新冠大流行期间发明的。这是一个什么游戏？她对她的六年级学生感到非常难过。他们其实还是孩子，你知道的，最多也就11、12岁，而且他们一整天上学都待在室内。他们根本没有任何课间休息。所以她想，好吧，如果我至少在学校上课前给他们半小时的时间玩耍，不是很好吗？他们中的一些人
arrived early anyway. And it turns out they arrived eagerly early when she provided that play opportunity. So she let them play in the ways that they wanted to play. And one of the games that they played, this was after COVID, was called something like infection, or maybe it was called COVID, something like that. And some of the children were infection. And if they touch somebody, you became infected and might die.
无论如何都会早到。事实证明，当她提供这个玩耍的机会时，他们都急切地早到了。所以她让他们按照自己想玩的方式玩。其中一个他们玩的游戏，是在新冠疫情之后，名字叫作诸如“感染”之类的，或者可能叫“新冠”，诸如此类。有些孩子是感染源。如果他们碰了某个人，你就被感染了，可能会死。
And others were called vaccine, and they could prevent you from dying by coming and touching you. It was quite an imaginative game. I have no idea how they developed, but the teacher said they were clearly having a lot of fun with that. But then one of the school administrators observed that and she said, no, we can't have games like that going on. We can't have people pretending to die. I've heard of many stories where recesses have been very much curtailed and limited
而其他人则被称为疫苗，他们可以通过过来触碰你来阻止你死亡。这是一个相当富有想象力的游戏。我不知道他们是怎么开发出来的，但老师说他们玩得非常开心。然而，其中一位学校管理者看到了这一幕，她说：“不行，我们不能进行这样的游戏。我们不能让人们假装死亡。”我听说过很多这样的故事，由于关于在玩耍中什么能做、什么不能做的规则，
because of rules about what you can and cannot do in play. Peter noticed something similar in his own life. When his son was little, both of them took part in something called a pinewood derby. Yeah, so this was designed to promote bonding between fathers and their sons and the boys were about eight years old at this time and the way it works is each father-son pair is given a kit that includes a piece of very soft pine wood about seven inches long and wheels that can be attached to it and the idea is to carve
课间休息被大大缩减和限制了。彼得在自己的生活中也注意到了类似的事情。当他的儿子还小的时候，父子俩都参加过一个叫作“松木车大赛”的活动。是的，这是为了促进父亲和儿子之间的感情而设计的，当时的男孩大约八岁左右。它的运作方式是，给每个父子组合一个工具包，里面包含一块大约七英寸长的非常软的松木，以及可以安装在上面的轮子，想法是把
the wood into something that looks like a race car and to attach the wheels and then you everybody brings them back to the next meeting of the group and and you race them down a slope. My interpretation of this was this was an opportunity for children to do something a little bit risky, using a knife to carve the soft wood and for fathers to help out. And that's the way we did it.
木头雕刻成赛车的样子，装上轮子，然后每个人把它们带到小组的下一次聚会上，在一个斜坡上进行比赛。我对这事的理解是，这是一个让孩子做一些稍微有点冒险的事情的机会，用刀子雕刻软木头，而父亲则在旁协助。我们当时就是这么做的。
And I was very proud of it. He was proud of it. And he painted it up himself and I showed him how to attach the wheels on and he did that. So I played a role kind of showing him how to do things. But then when we showed up, all the other cars were beautifully crasped. They were just so smooth, perfectly painted. And my son and I, we just almost left we we didn't even want his looked like it was made by an eight-year-old right yeah and I'm assuming the car probably didn't run as smoothly as some of the other cars that that had the
他对此感到自豪。他自己把车漆好，我教他怎么装轮子，他也照做了。所以我扮演了一个教他怎么做事的角色。但是当我们到那儿时，所有其他的车都工艺精美。它们是那么光滑，完美无瑕。我和我儿子，我们简直快笑出声了——我们甚至都不想比了——他的车看起来就像是个八岁小孩做的，对吧？是的，而且我猜这辆车可能不像其他那些拥有
superior craftsmanship of it did not run as smoothly as the others and I think the others refrained from laughing at us, but we were embarrassed. So there's a common pattern to all of these stories, Peter. A number of years ago, you began taking notice of what adults are doing when they interact with kids. What did you notice? In many ways, adults have taken over children's lives. I think in some sense with good intentions,
卓越工艺的车那样跑得那么顺畅，它的确没有其他的跑得顺畅，我想其他人强忍着没有笑话我们，但我们还是觉得很尴尬。所以所有这些故事都有一个共同的模式，彼得。多年前，你开始注意到成年人在与孩子互动时的行为。你注意到了什么？在许多方面，成年人已经接管了孩子的生活。我认为在某种意义上这是出于好意，
there's a lot of promotion of the idea that parents should be very much involved with their children's lives, that parents are expected almost these days, much more so than in the past, to kind of be teachers to their children, as well as comforters and nurturers and so on. And I think the cost of that has
社会上有很多人在宣传这样一种观点：父母应该极大地参与到孩子的生活中，如今的父母甚至被期望——比过去多得多——去充当孩子的老师，以及安慰者和抚育者等等。我认为这样做的代价是，
been that it takes away from children's own initiative, from children's own opportunities to figure things out for themselves and learn how to solve problems. You write that children perceive adults as potential enforcers of safety, solvers of conflicts, and audiences for whining, and this perception invites the children to act unsafely, to squabble, and to whine. Expand on that. Tell me what you mean. In my experience, children are actually take responsibility when there's no adults around. That's part of the advantage of there being no adults around. They have to take responsibility.
它剥夺了孩子的主动性，剥夺了孩子自己去搞清楚事情和学习如何解决问题的机会。你写道，孩子们把成年人视为潜在的安全执法者、冲突解决者和抱怨的倾听者，而这种看法反过来又引诱孩子们做出不安全行为、争吵和抱怨。请展开说说。告诉我这是什么意思。以我的经验，当周围没有成年人时，孩子们实际上会承担起责任。这也是周围没有成年人的好处的一部分。他们必须承担责任。
If there's no adults there to tell you what to do, you've got to kind of say, oh, is this safe or not safe? Is this a reasonable thing to do or not? And children are pretty good at that. But when there's adults around, at least in this day and age, they kind of assume the adults are responsible for deciding if it's safe or not. The adults are responsible if somebody's teasing you instead of for you to figure out what am I going to do about this person who's teasing me, you go and tell the adult. So even just the mere presence of That's the way it may seem from a grown-up perspective. But really, Peter says, when kids play by themselves, they learn to become rule inventors.
如果没有成年人在旁边告诉你该做什么，你就得自己琢磨：哦，这安全还是不安全？这样做合理吗？孩子们在这方面其实挺在行的。但当有成年人在场时，至少在当今时代，他们会想当然地认为成年人应该负责决定是否安全。如果有人戏弄你，成年人要负责；而不是由你自己去想：我该怎么对付这个戏弄我的人？你反而会去告大人。所以，仅仅是……的存在，从成年人的角度来看可能是这样的。但彼得说，事实上，当孩子们自己玩耍时，他们学会了成为规则的发明者。
Peter learned this at a family gathering when a couple of 10-year-old girls invited him to join their game of Scrabble. I kind of assumed, well, this is an opportunity for me to sort of teach them about Scrabble. I'm pretty good at Scrabble and I'm sure they're novices. I sat down to play Scrabble with them and started to explain the rules, but they had played the game before and went right into a game that was modeled after Scrabble, but it had their own rules. So instead of having to play an actual word, they could play any kind of a nonsense word as long as it sounded like a word. And the longer and sillier it sounded, the better.
彼得是在一次家庭聚会上了解到这一点的，当时几个10岁的小女孩邀请他加入她们的拼字游戏。我当时想当然地认为，这是一个向她们传授拼字游戏的好机会。我很擅长拼字游戏，而她们肯定都是新手。我坐下来和她们一起玩拼字游戏，并开始解释规则，但她们以前玩过这个游戏，并且直接进入了一个模仿拼字游戏但有自己规则的游戏。因此，她们不必拼出一个真正的单词，而是可以拼出任何胡言乱语的单词，只要它听起来像个词就行。
They had no interest in keeping score. They were just having a great time playing nonsense words and then they would once and well challenge the other person, what's the meaning of this? And then the other one would pretend to look it up in the dictionary and cite a very funny meaning that fit a little bit with the way it sounded. And I just sat back after a little bit of protest, like, hey, this is Scrabble, let's really play Scrabble. I just finally sat back and I realized, hey, these girls are really playing.
听起来越长、越傻越好。她们对记分毫无兴趣。她们只是在开心地玩着胡言乱语的词，然后偶尔会挑战对方：“这是什么意思？”接着另一个人会假装在字典里查阅，并说出一个非常搞笑的意思，这个意思还挺符合那个词的发音。我在小小的抗议了一阵之后——比如“嘿，这是拼字游戏，我们好好玩拼字游戏吧”——最终往后一靠，意识到：嘿，这些女孩真的在玩呢。
My way of playing Scrabble is a little bit more like work than like play. I understand your son Scott gave you something of a window into the effects that adults can have on children. He was not a fan of elementary school and perhaps that's putting it mildly. Putting it mildly is correct. He hated school right from the beginning
我玩拼字游戏的方式更像是工作，而不是玩耍。我理解你的儿子斯科特让你对成年人可能对儿童产生的影响有了一些了解。他不是小学的粉丝，也许这样说还是轻描淡写的。轻描淡写是正确的。他从一开始就讨厌学校，
and he complained all the way from kindergarten through fourth grade. He would come home and be angry. He would say, you know, they're acting like I'm a puppet and I'm supposed to just do what they're telling me to do. And I have no say in it. And of course, that's the way school works. But and I would say to him, well, just do what they tell you to do, you know, it's not that hard, just do it. You know, all kids in some ways have conflicts with parents and teachers, and so, you know, kids are unhappy at school, they're distracted, they're bored, they talk to their, you know, friends instead of studying or paying attention in class, and you know, they run
他从幼儿园一直抱怨到四年级。他放学回家时总是气冲冲的。他会说：“你知道吗，他们把我当成木偶，让我干嘛我就得干嘛。我根本没有发言权。”当然，学校就是这样运作的。但我会跟他说：“行了，他们让你干嘛你就干嘛，你知道的，这并不难，照做就行了。”你知道的，所有的孩子在某些方面都会与父母和老师发生冲突，所以，你知道的，孩子们在学校不开心、分心、无聊，他们和朋友聊天而不是学习或在课堂上集中注意力，你知道的，他们会遇到
into, they're run-ins with teachers. I mean, this is a routine part of childhood for almost all kids. What was he doing that was different? Was it actually, was it just that garden variety kind of rebellion or was it something more than that? Yeah, I mean, his rebellion was very different from the typical, you know, naughty boy, you know, who's maybe shooting spitballs or, and so on.
与老师的冲突。我的意思是，这对几乎所有的孩子来说都是童年时期司空见惯的一部分。他做的事情有什么不同？这真的只是一种寻常的叛逆，还是超越了这一范畴？是的，我的意思是，他的叛逆与典型的顽皮男孩非常不同，你知道的，那种可能会吐纸团的男孩等等。
His rebellion was almost like a planned rebellion. boy who's maybe shooting spitballs and so on. His rebellion was almost like a planned rebellion. So just for example, when the teacher would teach him a specific way of doing arithmetic problems and how you're supposed to show your work, he would deliberately find a different way to do it. And then the teachers complained to us about that and I asked him, so why do you do it a different way? And he said, it's because it's the only way I can make it fun.
他的叛逆几乎像是一场有计划的叛逆。可能会吐纸团的男孩等等。他的叛逆几乎像是一场有计划的叛逆。所以，举个例子，当老师教他一种做算术题的特定方法以及如何写出解题步骤时，他会故意找一种不同的方法来做。然后老师向我们抱怨这件事，我问他：“那你为什么要用不同的方法做呢？”他说：“因为这是我唯一能让它变得有趣的方法。”
And when they were teaching about punctuation and capital letters and how to put them into sentences, he actually declared, I'm going to write now like E.E. Cummings, the poet, and put punctuation in capitals wherever I please. So that was him. Ultimately, it led to a meeting in the principal's office in which his teacher, the principal, assistant principal, school psychologist, another psychologist called from outside, his mom and me, were all there to tell him
当老师教标点符号和大写字母以及如何在句子中使用它们时，他甚至宣称：“我现在要像诗人E.E.卡明斯那样写作，随心所欲地使用标点和大写字母。”这就是他。最终，这导致了一次校长办公室的会议，他的老师、校长、副校长、学校心理学家、另一位从外面请来的心理学家、他的妈妈和我都出席了，所有人都在那里毫不含糊地告诉他，
in no uncertain terms that he had to follow the rules of the school. And he, nine years old, looked at us big adults and he said, go to hell. As a dad, Peter knew something had to change. But as a researcher, he started to ask himself, is it possible the problem was not with kids like Scott, but with adults like himself? You're listening to Hidden Brain.
他必须遵守学校的规矩。而他，一个九岁的孩子，看着我们这一群大大人说：“见鬼去吧。”作为父亲，彼得知道必须做出改变。但作为一名研究人员，他开始扪心自问：有没有可能问题不在于像斯科特这样的孩子，而在于像他自己这样的成年人？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When it comes to rearing happy and healthy children, when should we lend a helping hand and when should we step away and let kids figure out things for themselves? At Boston College, psychologist Peter Gray studies what adults today do and what they ought to do to maximize the well-being of children. He says an important question parents, teachers, and school administrators should ask themselves when it comes to rules and structure is how much is too much. Peter, you decided to start your research by delving into what anthropologists have
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在抚养快乐健康的儿童时，我们什么时候该伸出援手，什么时候又该退后一步，让孩子们自己去搞清楚事情？在波士顿学院，心理学家彼得·格雷研究了如今的成年人在做什么，以及他们为了让儿童福祉最大化应该做什么。他说，当涉及到规则和结构时，父母、老师和学校管理者应该自问的一个重要问题是：多少才算太多？彼得，你决定从深入了解人类历史上育儿实践中人类学家的发现来开始你的研究。现代以前的典型模式是什么？
found about child-rearing practices throughout human history. What was the typical pattern before modern times? Yes, so I began to get interested in how children, historically, have acquired the culture that they're growing up in, learning from others what you need to know to succeed in that culture, eventually as an adult. And I'm an evolutionary psychologist, so I look at human nature from the perspective of Darwinian evolution. If you look at human nature from that perspective,
是的，所以我开始对儿童在历史上是如何获得他们成长过程中的文化的产生兴趣，从他人那里学习在该文化中获得成功所需要知道的东西，最终成为一个成年人。我是一名进化心理学家，所以我从达尔文进化的角度来看待人性。如果你从这个角度来看待人性，
you automatically become interested in hunter-gatherers, because we were all hunter-gatherers during 99% or so of our biological evolution. And as you undoubtedly know, there have been hunter-gatherers in isolated parts of the world who, at least into the middle to even late 20th century, were still living in a rather pristine hunter-gatherer way of life. And there were anthropologists who had trekked out into those areas to make contact with them and study them. And I began to read what I could of such work. And ultimately, along with a graduate student, surveyed a group of anthropologists who had studied various different groups of hunter-gatherers in different parts of the world
你自然会对狩猎采集者感兴趣，因为在我们大约99%的生物进化过程中，我们全都是狩猎采集者。正如你无疑知道的那样，世界上有些偏远地区仍然存在狩猎采集者，至少到20世纪中后期，他们仍然过着一种相当原始的狩猎采集生活方式。有些人类学家曾长途跋涉到这些地区与他们接触并进行研究。我开始阅读此类作品中我能找到的所有内容。最终，我和一名研究生一起，调查了一组人类学家，他们曾研究过世界不同地区的各种不同的狩猎采集者群体，
to find out from them what are children's lives like in the culture that they observe. What's the relationship between adults and children? And what I found in every case, seven different cultures on three different continents was that the children were free to play and explore pretty much all day long. They might be asked to do little chores, but no such thing as school. You know, the adults might say, you know, don't eat these mushrooms, they're poisonous. They would point out things that are dangerous. But the assumption was that children would learn by observing, by exploring, by playing.
以了解他们在所观察的文化中儿童的生活是怎样的。成年人与儿童之间的关系是怎样的？我在每一种情况下——三个不同大洲的七种不同文化中——发现的是，孩子们几乎一整天都可以自由地玩耍和探索。他们可能会被要求做一些小零活，但根本没有学校这回事。你知道，成年人们可能会说：“不要吃这些蘑菇，它们有毒。”他们会指出危险的事物。但大家的假设是，孩子们会通过观察、探索和玩耍来学习。
And when I asked the anthropologists, well, what did the children play at? They talked about play that seemed to be, in essentially every case, modeled after the activities that were important to the culture in which they were growing up. So in a culture where the men hunt big game, the little boys and middle-sized boys too, were playing at hunting big game.
当我问人类学家：“孩子们玩些什么？”他们谈到的游戏，在基本上所有情况下，似乎都是以他们成长过程中对该文化重要的活动为模范的。所以，在一个成年男性狩猎大型猎物的文化中，小男孩和中等身材的男孩们也在玩狩猎大型猎物的游戏。
In a culture where they used dugout canoes, the kids were playing with dugout canoes and so on and so forth. They played at the games and music and art of the culture. And not because anybody was requiring them to do so, but because it just seemed apparently natural for them to do that. And what the anthropologist pointed out is they would play at these things and eventually they were actually doing these things. The play would merge into adult-like activity. So there was no real difference between what you're doing when you're playing and what you're doing when you are an adult actually doing this thing that you were playing
在一个使用独木舟的文化中，孩子们就在玩独木舟，诸如此类。他们玩该文化的传统游戏、音乐和艺术。不是因为任何人强迫他们这样做，而是因为这样做对他们来说似乎是极其自然的。正如人类学家所指出的，他们在玩这些东西的过程中，最终实际上就在做这些事情。游戏会融合成类似于成年人的活动。因此，当你玩耍时所做的事情，与你作为一个成年人真正做你之前玩耍时所模仿的事情之间，并没有真正的区别。
at before. So this was very interesting to me. And of course the the children would have been hanging out with a range of other children probably of different ages. Presumably they would be learning not just from children who are exactly their own age, but from children who are a little older. And those children might have learned things from children who are a little older than them. That's a very important observation that these are all banned cultures. So they're relatively small. Even if you wanted to just hang out with kids your own age, there wouldn't be enough. So you're always playing with kids who are both older and younger than yourself. So a typical play group might be kids from age four to 12 or
所以这让我非常感兴趣。当然，孩子们会和一堆其他年龄可能不同的孩子在一起。据推测，他们不仅会从年龄和他们完全相同的孩子那里学习，还会从比他们大一点的孩子那里学习。而这些孩子可能又从比他们大一点的孩子那里学到了东西。这是一个非常重要的观察结果，即这些都是小规模的群体。因此它们相对较小。即使你只想和同龄的孩子在一起，人数也不够。所以你总是和比你大或比你小的孩子一起玩。因此，一个典型的游戏小组可能是从4岁到12岁的孩子，或者
age eight to 16, all playing together. But when children are playing across age, the younger children are always learning from the older children. They're being boosted up to higher levels of activity and the older children are in a very important way learning from younger children. They're learning how to be leaders, they're learning how to be caretakers, they're learning in some sense how to be teachers as they're explaining to the younger children how to do whatever it is that they're doing. So your research suggests that when adults leave children alone to play and learn and socialize in their own way, kids become more likely to develop a range of skills.
8岁到16岁的孩子，大家都在一起玩。但是当孩子们跨年龄玩耍时，年幼的孩子总是在向年长的孩子学习。他们被带到更高水平的活动中，而年长的孩子则在非常重要的方面向年幼的孩子学习。他们在学习如何成为领导者，在学习如何成为照顾者，在某种意义上，当他们向年幼的孩子解释如何做他们正在做的事情时，他们也在学习如何成为老师。所以你的研究表明，当成年人让孩子们独自玩耍、学习并以他们自己的方式进行社交时，孩子们更有可能发展出一系列技能。
Like what Peter? I could really run through all of the basic skills that children have to develop in any culture in order to succeed. These are social skills. These are the skills of knowing how to initiate an activity and direct that activity, problem-solving skills. Children practice these skills when they're playing and when they're playing with other children. When adults are around, adults step in and solve the problems for the children. The adults tell them how to play and the children therefore are not learning how to take initiative, not learning how to create rules for themselves, not learning how to negotiate with other children to solve
比如什么，彼得？我可以顺便列举一下儿童在任何文化中为了成功而必须发展的基本技能。这些是社交技能。这些是如何发起一项活动并指导该活动的技能，也就是解决问题的技能。当孩子们在玩耍以及与其他孩子玩耍时，他们就在练习这些技能。当成年人在场时，成年人会介入并为孩子们解决问题。成年人会告诉他们怎么玩，因此孩子们就没有学会如何采取主动，没有学会为自己制定规则，没有学会与其他孩子谈判以解决
problems. If there's always an adult there, doing it for them. And in some ways I suppose all of this points back to the central thing that children need to learn, which is to learn to be independent. Perhaps we're taking that away from them. That's well put because again from an evolutionary perspective, what do we even have this long period of childhood? What is the purpose of the juvenile period, as we would say, in all mammals? It is to develop the skills that allow you to become increasingly independent. But the only way you can develop those skills is by being allowed increasing amounts of independence as you are growing older from year to year. That used to occur in our culture. That was certainly true when I was a child many, many decades ago. And
问题，因为总有一个成年人在那里替他们代劳。在某种程度上，我想这一切都指向了孩子们需要学习的核心事情，那就是学会独立。也许我们正在把这一点从他们身上剥夺。这话说得很好，因为再次从进化的角度来看，我们为什么会有这么长一段童年期？用我们所有哺乳动物的话来说，青少年期的目的是什么？它是为了发展能够让你变得越来越独立的技能。但你唯一能发展这些技能的方法，就是在逐年成长的过程中，被允许获得越来越多的独立性。这在我们的文化中曾经是存在的。几十年前我还是个孩子的时候，情况确实如此。
it was even true when my son was a child fewer decades ago. But today we are not allowing children to do the things that they should be doing, that they're capable of doing for a variety of reasons. But the end result is that children are more or less supervised, directed, monitored, corrected all the time. You say that when children spend a lot of time in the company of adults, they are less likely to participate in what you call authentic communication. And they're more likely to do this when they're in the company of other children. What do you mean by this term, Peter?
甚至在我儿子几年前还是个孩子的时候也是如此。但今天，由于各种原因，我们不允许孩子去做他们应该做的、他们有能力做的事情。但最终的结果是，孩子们或多或少地一直受到监督、指导、监控和纠正。你说，当孩子们花大量时间与成年人共处时，他们就不太可能参与你所说的“真实沟通”。而当他们和别的孩子在一起时，他们更有可能这样做。彼得，你这个词是什么意思？
Let me refer to a research study that was done some time ago. These researchers recorded children's voices while they were playing with other children. These were young children, about probably five or six years old, and then also recorded them when they were in class talking with their teacher and also recorded them when they were just sitting around having lunch. When they
让我参考一下不久前做的一项研究。这些研究人员记录了孩子们与其他孩子玩耍时的声音。这些是年幼的儿童，大概五六岁左右，然后还记录了他们在课堂上与老师交谈时的声音，以及他们只是坐在一起吃午餐时的声音。当他们
were playing the language was far more sophisticated, far more real, far more authentic than in any other situation. because when you're playing with other kids you're constantly negotiating you know maybe picture a group of young children playing that they're going to the King's ball and you know who's going to marry the prince and so then there's a discussion about that or who gets to wear this beautiful set of necklaces that you find in the dress-up corner of the kindergarten room? So who, and so there's constant, they spend more time negotiating and discussing what they're doing than actually
在玩耍时，语言要复杂得多、真实得多、地道得多，远胜于任何其他情境。因为当你和其他孩子玩耍时，你总是在谈判，你知道的，也许可以想象一群小孩子在玩要去国王的舞会上，你知道谁要嫁给王子，于是大家就此展开讨论，或者谁能戴上你在幼儿园角色扮演角里找到的那套漂亮的项链？所以谁，于是他们花在谈判和讨论他们正在做的事情上的时间，要多于实际
playing it out, which is a good thing because that's how you think of what they're learning when they do that. They're learning this incredibly important skill of being able to use words, language, to decide mutually what they're doing as a group. How are we going to play this game? You say that when kids interact with adults, they don't get the same kind of authentic feedback that they get when they are interacting with other children. Can you give me some examples of what you
把事情演出来的闭门造车，这是一件好事，因为这就是你在他们这样做时所看到他们正在学习的东西。他们正在学习这种极其重要的技能，即能够使用词语、语言，来作为集体共同决定我们在做什么：我们该怎么玩这个游戏？你说当孩子们与成年人互动时，他们得不到那种他们在与其他孩子互动时能得到的真实的反馈。你能举几个例子说明你
mean by this? Well, you know, sometimes it's just ridiculous. You'll hear a parent or an adult say to a child, so, Billy, what color is that? Oh my gosh. This is so patronizing. It's as if the purpose of the discussion is always kind of pedantic to try to teach the child something rather than an actual, authentic back and forth discussion. And I suppose also there is some pressure
这是什么意思吗？嗯，你知道，有时这简直荒谬。你会听到父母或成年人对孩子说：“那么，比利，那个颜色是什么？”哦天哪。这太居高临下了。就好像讨论的目的总是带有某种学究气，试图教给孩子点什么，而不是一种真实、地道的来回讨论。我想同时也有一些压力，
that parents and teachers feel to give positive feedback. So when the four-year-old comes back with a scribble on a page, there is some pressure to say this is a masterpiece. Yes, unlike kids. I'll give you what I think is a nice example of this. In one of the situations where I was observing age-mixed play and how seven and eight-year-old children
就是父母和老师觉得必须给出积极的反馈。所以当四岁的孩子带着一页涂鸦回来时，就会有一种压力去说这是一件杰作。是的，孩子们可不这样。我给你举一个我认为很好的例子。在我观察混合年龄游戏的情境之一中，七八岁的孩子
playing card games with children who are somewhat older. And I was observing how the older children would keep the younger children on task. And they would say things like, Hey, stupid, you know, pay attention. You know, this is that what a typical parent today would say. But the kids, I think actually, the little kids I think appreciated that because this is genuine coming from an older kid. This kid is not trying to patronize you in some way. You also say that in the course of playing,
和年龄稍大的孩子一起玩纸牌游戏。我观察到年长的孩子是如何让年幼的孩子专注于任务的。他们会说这样的话：“嘿，笨蛋，你知道的，注意点。这可不是现在的典型父母会说的话。”但我认为小孩子们其实很感激这一点，因为这是来自大孩子的真诚反应。这个孩子并不是在以某种方式居高临下地对待你。你还说在玩耍的过程中，
children come to understand that rules in fact are invented things. They are things that have been invented by other people and that they can be modified and changed. And it's harder to do that if you believe that rules are sacrosanct and handed down to you by an all-powerful adult. One way to think about this is the difference between,
孩子们开始明白，规则实际上是人为发明的东西。它们是其他人发明的东西，是可以被修改和改变的。如果你认为规则是神圣不可侵犯的，是由全能的成年人传授给你的，那就很难做到这一点。思考这个问题的一种方法是区分
let's say, little league baseball, a pickup game of baseball, the way we used to play it when I was a kid. You know, there'd be a bunch of kids who would show up in the vacant lot, and there was never 18 players.'d be a bunch of kids who would show up in the vacant lot and there was never 18 players. We had to kind of figure out how we're going to make up the sides. We had to create ground rules. Anything hidden in the direction of those windows over there,
比如说，少儿棒球联赛和随性棒球赛，也就是我小时候我们常玩的那种。你知道，会有许多孩子出现在空地上，从来不会正好有18个球员。会有许多孩子出现在空地上，从来不会正好有18个球员。我们得自己想办法怎么分队。我们得制定地面规则。任何打向那边那些窗户方向的球，
that's an automatic out and so on. Have to pitch soft to little Timmy. We'd make up all the rules so there'd be fun for everybody and fair for everybody. This is just the way kids always play. Little League, you play by the official rules of baseball. You don't vary them. You just do it. And there's adults there making sure you follow those rules. You say that one reason adults are less inclined to give children the freedom they used to have is that adults are increasingly concerned about their children's safety. When did this fear arise Peter and how does it affect the lives of children? So when I was a kid many decades ago the regular song of parents was get out of the house. Get out of the house. I don't want you around.
都是自动出局，诸如此类。投球要对小蒂姆温柔点。我们会编造所有的规则，好让每个人都觉得好玩且公平。这就是孩子们一贯的玩耍方式。而在少儿棒球联赛中，你必须按照棒球的官方规则来玩。你不能改变它们。你只能照做。而且有成年人在场确保你遵守这些规则。你说，成年人越来越不愿给孩子他们过去拥有的自由的一个原因是，成年人越来越担心孩子的安全。这种恐惧是什么时候出现的，彼得，它又是如何影响儿童生活的？所以在我几十年前还是个孩子的时候，父母们的口头禅就是：滚出屋去。滚出屋去。我不想看见你。
So kids were outdoors and they'd find one another and they play with one another. This was not just the 1950s and 1960s America. This is the way hunter gatherer children played as I described before. This is generally the way children throughout the world have played. And so this is a new thing in some sense in the history of the world where we are not allowing children independent activity away from adults. We've got adults around them all the time. But talk a little bit about sort of the concern for safety
所以孩子们都在户外，他们会找到彼此并一起玩耍。这不仅是20世纪50年代和60年代的美国。这也是正如我之前所描述的狩猎采集者儿童的玩耍方式。这通常是世界各地儿童的玩耍方式。所以在某种程度上，这是世界历史上的一个新事物，我们不允许儿童进行独立于成年人的活动。我们的成年人一直围着他们。但请谈谈对安全的担忧，
and sort of the concern that many parents have that if they were to give kids the kind of freedom that they had before that bad things could happen to them. Yeah, so if you ask parents why they're not allowing their children outside, you'll get a variety of answers. Some of them are quite legitimate. One of them is, well, there's nobody else outside and so my child goes outside to play and there's nobody to play with. Or, you know, I've heard of this case recently in our neighborhood where somebody let their child out
以及许多父母所担忧的：如果他们给孩子以前那种自由，不好的事情可能会降临到他们身上。是的，所以如果你问父母为什么不让孩子去户外，你会得到各种各样的答案。其中一些是相当合理的。其中一个是：“嗯，外面没有其他人，所以我孩子出去玩时连个一起玩的人都没有。”或者，“你知道的，我最近在我们社区听说过这样的案例：有人让孩子出去
to play with other children and somebody called the police, and then protective services arrived. So the culture has changed such that you are considered to be a negligent parent if you allow your child outside without observing that child. Now, why did the culture change? And I think that the biggest change occurred in the 1980s. There were a couple of cases of young boys, in both cases they were six years old, one of these instances occurred actually in 1979 and the other in 1981, who were taken by a stranger on the street and ultimately murdered. This is, of course, a very rare event and because it's rare, it made headlines,
跟其他孩子玩，结果有人报警了，然后儿童保护服务机构就来了。”所以文化已经发生了变化，如果你允许你的孩子在没有观察的情况下外出，你就会被认为是一个疏忽大意的父母。那么，文化为什么会变呢？我认为最大的变化发生在20世纪80年代。有两起小男孩失踪的案件，两人都是六岁，其中一起发生于1979年，另一起发生于1981年，他们在街上被陌生人带走并最终被谋杀。这当然是一件非常罕见的事件，正因为罕见，它成了头条新闻，
it was in the news all the time, and it led to programs trying to protect, make sure that this doesn't happen again. And among those programs was to put pictures on milk cartons of missing children. And the assumption was that when you were eating your breakfast cereal and looking at this milk carton that these missing children were people, little kids who had been snatched away by some stranger on the street. And the whole concept of stranger danger was developed. And once a person has this image in their head, it's hard to get it out of your head. So it leads to a belief that the world is more dangerous than it actually is. The truth of the matter is the world is not more dangerous today than it was decades ago.
它一直在新闻里播报，并催生了各种旨在保护、确保这种情况不再发生的项目。这些项目之一就是在牛奶盒上印上失踪儿童的照片。当时的想法是，当你吃着早餐麦片看着这个牛奶盒时，这些失踪的儿童就是那些被街上的某个陌生人抢走的小孩子。整个“陌生人危险”的概念就这样发展起来了。而一旦一个人脑子里有了这种形象，就很难把它赶出脑海。这导致了一种信念，即世界比实际情况更加危险。事实的真相是，世界并没有比几十年前更危险。
You know it's also the case that families are having fewer children today. This is not just in the United States, it's in many countries around the world. And I'm not necessarily suggesting that parents who have many kids, you know, love their children any less than parents who have few kids. But it is certainly the case that I think parents direct more attention to their kids now, in part because families are smaller, and that's driven by demographic and economic changes
你知道，现在的家庭生孩子也越来越少了。这不仅在美国，在世界上的许多国家都是如此。我并不是一定要暗示那些生很多孩子的父母，你知道的，他们爱孩子就比生少数孩子的父母少。但可以肯定的是，我认为父母现在对孩子的关注更多了，部分原因是家庭规模变小了，而这是由人口和经济变化驱动的，
that are probably well beyond the control of any individual. I think that is definitely a contributing factor. When you have more kids, you're more likely to want some of them out of the house, if not all of them out of the house, right? And houses have gotten bigger too. When you've got a small house and a bunch of kids,
这些变化可能远远超出了任何个人的控制范围。我认为这绝对是一个促成因素。当你有很多孩子时，你更有可能想让其中一些人甚至全部人离开屋子，对吧？而且房子也变得越来越大了。当你有一个小房子和一群孩子时，
you don't want them all hanging around the house. You say that another reason adults have intruded in their children's lives is that increasingly many adults feel the need to prepare children for a very competitive world. Talk about this idea, Peter. Yes, I think we have become over time increasingly concerned about our children's competitiveness. We in the United States are a competitive culture to begin with. And the other thing that's happened, I think, really ever since about 1980,
你可不想让他们都在屋里晃荡。你说，成年人干涉儿童生活的另一个原因是，越来越多的成年人感到有必要让孩子为一个竞争激烈的世界做好准备。谈谈这个想法，彼得。是的，我认为随着时间的推移，我们对孩子的竞争力的关注越来越多。我们在美国本来就是一个竞争激烈的文化。另一件发生的事情是，我认为实际上自1980年前后以来，
there's been continuous growth in the gap between the rich and the poor in this country. And there's actually research indicating that when the gap between rich and poor is great, parents become increasingly anxious about their children's future, especially as the job market changes in ways that most parents don't necessarily understand and are kind of unpredictable. And there's a lot of pressure on kids and creates a more competitive schooling environment than was present before.
这个国家贫富差距一直在持续扩大。事实上，有研究表明，当贫富差距很大时，父母对孩子未来的焦虑就会增加，特别是当就业市场以大多数父母不一定理解且有些不可预测的方式发生变化时。孩子们面临着很大的压力，这创造了一个比以往更具竞争力的学校环境。
You say that there are serious consequences of depriving children of unstructured and unsupervised play. What are the effects of excessive adult supervision on the social, emotional, and intellectual development of children? Over the same decades that we have been gradually decreasing children's opportunities to play independently of adults, we have seen a continuous rise in anxiety and depression and tragically even suicide among school-aged kids. So of course that correlation doesn't by itself prove a cause and effect relationship, but that's the first step for believing. Well, maybe the fact that children are not playing and exploring and doing things independently,
你说剥夺儿童进行无结构和无监督玩耍的权利会产生严重的后果。过度成年人监督对儿童的社会、情感和智力发展有什么影响？在过去的几十年里，我们一直在逐渐减少儿童在没有成年人监督的情况下独立玩耍的机会，与此同时，我们看到学龄儿童的焦虑、悲伤、甚至不幸的是自杀率在持续上升。所以当然，这种相关性本身并不能证明因果关系，但这却是建立信仰的第一步。好吧，也许是因为孩子们没有在独立玩耍、探索和做事情，
maybe that's why they are so anxious, so depressed, so unhappy, so lacking in the resilience that we wish they would have. Now there's both theoretical reasons and empirical reasons for believing that there is this cause-effect relationship. Can you tell me a little bit about that? What is the evidence? So let me begin with just the theoretical part. Play makes children happy. That shouldn't have, we didn't have to prove that, right? I mean play is what makes children happy. We shouldn't have to prove that, right? I mean, play is what makes children happy.
也许这就是为什么他们如此焦虑、如此抑郁、如此不快乐，如此缺乏我们希望他们拥有的应变能力。现在，有理论和经验上的理由相信存在这种因果关系。你能跟我讲讲这个吗？证据是什么？所以我先从理论部分开始。游戏能让孩子们快乐。这不需要，我们不需要证明这一点，对吧？我的意思是，游戏是让孩子们快乐的东西。我们不应该去证明这一点，对吧？我的意思是，游戏是让孩子们快乐的东西。
It's also the case in other kinds of independent activities. Children feel good, they feel proud when they can do things by themselves. You know, it gives you a sense of confidence and so on. So you take that away from children and right off, they're going to be less happy. And famous play researcher Brian Sutton Smith, who died a few years ago, and he used to say the opposite of play
在其他种类的独立活动中也是如此。孩子们会感到高兴，当他们能自己做事情时，他们会感到自豪。你知道，这能给你一种自信等等。所以你把这些从孩子身上夺走，马上，他们就会不那么快乐。著名的游戏研究员布赖恩·萨顿-史密斯（Brian Sutton Smith）于几年前去世，他过去常说，游戏的对立面
is depression. And I think in a sense he's right that if you take away play from people they're going to be depressed. But in addition to that, what research shows is that when children are playing and doing other things independently, they are acquiring the skills and the sense of agency, the sense of what psychologists call an internal locus of control that leads them to recognize that they can solve problems. They can deal with the bumps in the road of life. You're dealing with that when you're playing. You know, somebody is bullying you a little bit and instead of a parent or an adult solving the problem, you figure out how to solve that problem or you get hurt and you figure out what to do
是抑郁。我认为在某种程度上他是对的，如果你把游戏从人们身边拿走，他们就会感到抑郁。但除此之外，研究表明，当孩子们在玩耍和独立做其他事情时，他们正在获得技能和自主感，也就是心理学家所说的那种内控点，这让他们认识到自己可以解决问题。他们能够应对生活道路上的坎坷。你在玩耍时就是在应对这些。你知道，有人稍微欺负你一下，与其由父母或成年人来解决问题，不如你自己想办法解决问题，或者你受伤了，然后你想办法处理
about it or you get lost and you find your way home. All of these are the kinds of experiences that children throughout history have always experienced and it's how they learn I can deal with problems I don't have to be afraid of the world because I can solve these problems But if we're not allowing children to do that, they don't develop this internal sense of control That sets you up to be anxious and if it goes too far It sets you up to be depressed and if it goes too far it sets you up to be depressed, a sense of hopelessness about the world. So those are the theoretical reasons. The empirical reasons come from a whole range of other kinds of studies that show that those children who do have more opportunity for independent play are doing better psychologically than those who have less. Do you think there are any positives, Peter, to the increased involvement of adults in children's lives?
这件事，或者你迷路了，然后找到了回家的路。所有这些都是孩子们在历史上一直经历的各种体验，正是通过这些，他们才学会了“我能够应对问题，我不需要害怕世界，因为我能解决这些问题”。但是，如果我们不允许孩子们这样做，他们就不会培养出这种内在的控制感。这会让你变得焦虑；如果过头了，它会让你变得抑郁；如果再过头了，它会让你感到抑郁，对世界产生一种绝望感。所以这些是理论上的原因。经验上的原因来自其他一系列的研究，这些研究表明，那些有更多机会进行独立游戏的儿童在心理上的表现要比那些机会较少的好。Peter，你认为成年人越来越多地参与到孩子的生活中，有什么积极的一面吗？
You could point to some positive changes. There are fewer teenage traffic accidents because fewer teenagers are driving. There's actually less sex among teenagers than in the past. So historically, in many ways, we might regard it as a good thing. There are fewer sexually transmitted diseases among young people. There's fewer unwanted pregnancies and so on than in the past. So some people point to those things as positive developments that have occurred from the fact that there's much more adult involvement in children's lives. When we come back, how to balance the imperatives of exploration and safety.
你可以指出一些积极的变化。青少年的交通事故减少了，因为开车的青少年变少了。事实上，现在的青少年性行为也比过去少。因此，从历史上看，在许多方面，我们可能会把它视为一件好事。年轻人的性传播疾病减少了。意外怀孕等情况也比过去少了。所以有些人指出这些是积极的发展，这些发展源于成年人更多地参与到孩子的生活中。当我们回来时，如何平衡探索和安全的必要性。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Peter Gray is a psychologist at Boston College. He's the author of Free to Learn, why unleleashing the Instinct to Play Will Make Our Children Happier, More Self-Reliant, and Better Students for Life. Peter, you've laid out some of the problems that arise from our present-day approach to parenting and education. You say that we can get a glimpse of what a healthier culture
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。彼得·格雷（Peter Gray）是波士顿学院（Boston College）的心理学家。他是《自由学习：为什么释放游戏本能会让我们的孩子更快乐、更自主、成为终身更好的学生》（Free to Learn, Why Unleashing the Instinct to Play Will Make Our Children Happier, More Self-Reliant, and Better Students for Life）一书的作者。彼得，你列举了我们当今的育儿和教育方法所产生的一些问题。你说，我们可以通过回顾过去，一窥更健康的童年文化
of childhood would look like by turning to the past. What was your own childhood like, Peter? I was a kid in the 1950s, which was a time there were a lot of kids. We moved a lot, but I found I made friends very quickly because all I had to do was to go outdoors and I would find other kids. And certainly by the time I started school, I was walking to school by myself, as was everybody else. When Peter turned five,
会是什么样子。彼得，你自己的童年是怎样的？我是20世纪50年代的孩子，那个时候有很多孩子。我们搬过很多次家，但我发现我交朋友的速度非常快，因为我所需要做的就是走到户外，然后我就会找到其他孩子。当然，到我开始上学的时候，我是自己走路去学校的，就像其他人一样。当彼得五岁时，
his family moved from Minneapolis to a small town in Southern Minnesota. Job number one for little Peter, find new friends. I remember my mother saying, well, why don't you just go door to door, knock on the doors, and ask if there are any children there your age?
他的家人从明尼阿波利斯搬到了明尼苏达州南部的一个小镇。小彼得的第一号任务：寻找新朋友。我记得我母亲说，嗯，你为什么不挨家挨户去敲门，问问那里有没有跟你年龄差不多的孩子？
So I did that all by myself, went door to door, and it turns out that right across the street the mom came to the door and I said, do you have any children who are about my age? And she said, yes, yes, I've got a daughter, Ruby Lou. And so Ruby Lou came to the door, and we went out to play, and Ruby Lou very quickly became my best friend. Tell me a little bit about her.
所以我一个人做了这件事，挨家挨户地敲门，结果马路对面的妈妈来开门，我说，你们家有跟我差不多大的孩子吗？她说，有，有，我有一个女儿，鲁比·露（Ruby Lou）。于是鲁比·露走到门前，我们出去玩了，鲁比·露很快就成了我的好朋友。跟我讲讲她的事吧。
What would you do together? So Ruby Lou was a little bit older than me. She started school before I did, but it's partly just the difference in when her birthday was. And she was kind of bolder than I was. I was kind of a shy kid in some ways, a little bit afraid of heights and so on. But she was a great tree climber. She showed me how to climb the trees and I would she would challenge me to climb higher and higher in the
你们会一起做什么？所以鲁比·露比我大一点。她比我先上学，但这部分是因为她生日的时间不同。而且她比我更大胆。在某些方面我算是个害羞的孩子，有点恐高等等。但她是个爬树高手。她向我展示了怎么爬树，我会，她会挑战我在树上爬得越来越高。
trees. I think the the story that I remember best is that she had a bicycle. I at that point did not have a bicycle. And I was really eager to learn how to ride a bicycle. So she said, well, I'll teach you how to ride a bicycle. So it turns out the street between our houses was on a small slope. And so she said, well the easiest way to learn how to ride a bicycle is start at the top of the slope and give yourself a push and then you just start pedaling and go as far as you can go and see if
我想我记的最清楚的故事是她有一辆自行车。当时我没有自行车。我真的很渴望学会骑自行车。所以她说，好吧，我教你骑自行车。结果发现，我们两家之间的街道在一个小坡上。所以她说，嗯，学习骑自行车最简单的方法是从坡顶开始，自己推一下，然后你就可以开始踩踏板，能骑多远就骑多远，看看
you can go a little farther every time. I mean what wonderful instructions for how to ride a bicycle. And so I did that and her bike was a girl's bike, which made it easier to learn because I didn't have to swing my leg up over that bar. And so she taught me how to ride a bicycle. Then once I could ride a bicycle, I convinced my parents to buy me a secondhand bike. She and I would take bicycle trips all around town and my mother said, it's fine for me.
你是不是每次都能骑得更远一点。我的意思是，关于如何骑自行车的指令是多么棒啊。于是我就照做了，她的自行车是一辆女式自行车，这让学习变得更容易，因为我不必把腿抬过那根横梁。于是她教我骑自行车。一旦我会骑自行车了，我就说服父母给我买了一辆二手自行车。她和我会在镇上到处骑自行车旅行，我母亲说，这对我来说很好。
I could, by myself, I had to stay within the town limits on the bike, but with Ruby Lou, it would be okay to go wherever we wanted because she assumed Ruby Lou was wiser and a little older and smarter than I was. I think she was. And we could go places together. I understand you played a lot of sports,
我可以独自一人，我必须骑车呆在镇界内，但有了鲁比·露，去我们想去的任何地方都可以，因为她认为鲁比·露更明智、年纪稍大一点，也比我更聪明。我想她是这样的。我们可以一起去一些地方。我听说你玩了很多体育运动，
but these were not like the adult organized sports teams that we have today. Yeah, so the kids were all into baseball there and we would just get together whenever we could on the vacant lot, whatever kids were around and we create our own baseball games. And so each team had to sort of choose their own player to who would kind of be the coach who would decide, you know, who's going to play what positions and so on and so forth. And for some reason, even though I was one of the youngest players,
但这些不像我们今天见到的那种由成人组织的运动队。是的，所以那里的孩子们都非常喜欢棒球，只要有机会，我们就会在空地上聚在一起，不管周围有哪些孩子，我们都会自己组织棒球比赛。所以每个球队都得挑选自己的球员，选出谁来当教练，由他来决定，你知道的，谁来打什么位置等等。不知为什么，尽管我是年纪最小的球员之一，
the players chose me on my team to be the coach. So that meant that I was the one who had to remind people when the games were, I had to decide who was going to pitch. Everybody wanted to pitch. So I had to figure out some rotating way to please everybody. I mean, the biggest challenge,
但队友们还是选我来当教练。这意味着我是那个必须提醒大家什么时候比赛的人，我必须决定谁来投球。每个人都想投球。所以我必须想出一种轮流的方式来取悦所有人。我的意思是，最大的挑战，
of course, you have in a situation like this is you want everybody to stay on the team, you want to keep everybody happy. And it was kind of a very much an adult like responsibility to manage this team when I was, I suppose I would have been about eight years old at that time. But there were no adults, adults never came to these games, you know, that the only adult involved was it probably was a teenager who would be an umpire there who would call balls and strikes and fall fair and foul. And that's what made it different from our pickup games. I mean, it would be hard to imagine an eight or nine year old in charge of a little league baseball team today. That's right. This is a change in our expectations. It's not a change in what people are capable
当然，在这样一种情况下，你希望每个人都留在队里，你希望让每个人都开心。当我还只有——我想我当时大概八岁左右的时候，管理这支球队就像是一种非常成人化的责任。但没有成年人，成年人从不来看这些比赛，你知道的，唯一涉及的成年人可能是一个青少年，他在那里担任裁判，负责判好球和坏球、界内球和界外球。这就是它与我们的即兴比赛的不同之处。我的意思是，很难想象今天会有一个八九岁的孩子负责一支小联盟棒球队。没错。这是我们期望值的改变。这并不是人们生物学上能力的改变，但在其他文化和狩猎采集文化中，你对这样的事情是不会感到惊讶的。
of biologically, but it's in other cultures and huster-gather cultures, you would not be surprised by something like this. That an eight year old could take that kind of responsibility. Now clearly it was a different time, a different era, but you have some suggestions on how we might bring back an element of playfulness into children's lives in our present day. And you say that parents can ask a simple question to their children that could get the ball rolling. What is this question, Peter? What is something that you really would like to do, that you feel you could do, but you'd like to do on your own? And initiate that conversation. See what the child says. And
一个八岁的孩子可以承担那种责任。现在这显然是一个不同的时代，一个不同的纪元，但你有一些关于如何在当今时代将趣味性元素带回儿童生活的建议。你说父母可以问孩子一个简单的问题，从而让事情顺利展开。这个问题是什么，彼得？有什么事情是你真的很想做，觉得自已也能做，但又想自己一个人做的吗？然后开启这段对话。看看孩子怎么说。
maybe the child will say, well, you know, I'd like to be able to ride my bicycle all by myself to my friend's house. Or maybe the child will say, I'd actually like to cook dinner. But now the child is asked and the parent is having this discussion. And the idea would be to reach some kind of a kind of agreement. Well, OK, you can do this. And it may not be exactly what the child's asking for, but something that the parent thinks is okay. So that kind of breaks into this cycle where you sort of change the discussion.
也许孩子会说，嗯，你知道，我想自己一个人骑自行车去朋友家。或者孩子会说，我其实想做晚饭。但现在孩子被问了，父母也在进行这场讨论。这个想法是达成某种一致。好吧，你可以这样做。它可能不完全是孩子所要求的，但却是父母认为可以接受的事情。所以这打破了这种循环，你相当于改变了讨论的内容。
It's not now just about safety. It's now about balancing safety with an acknowledged value in independent activity. And an acknowledgement that what the child wants to do is actually important. You see that parents can also work with other like-minded adults to make space and time for lightly supervised play. How would this work? This has actually occurred in some neighborhoods. I wish it occurred more. Where some parent or maybe more than one parent have decided, you know, we really would like our children to have more opportunities to play without us intervening. We remember our own
现在的焦点不再只是安全。现在焦点变成了在平衡安全的同时，承认独立活动的价值。并且承认孩子想做的事情其实很重要。你认为父母还可以与其他志同道合的成年人合作，为轻度监督的游戏留出空间和时间。这该如何运作？这实际上已经在一些社区发生过了。我希望它发生得更多。一些父母或不止一个父母决定，你知道，我们真的很希望我们的孩子有更多不需要我们干涉就能玩耍的机会。我们记得我们自己
experiences as children and what we benefited from play. We need to provide this for our children. How can we do it? And so one strategy is to get together with the neighbors who have kids and you say, all right, every Saturday we're all going to send our kids out and keep your devices inside. We're going to send you out, but they're all going out. If some of the parents are concerned about safety, we'll have one adult out there just for safety. In my opinion, ideally, that adult is a grandparent, because I find that grandparents tend to be a little less likely to intervene than parents are. But the understanding would be that that adult is there like a little less likely to intervene than parents are. But the understanding
作为孩子的经历以及我们从游戏中获益的地方。我们需要为我们的孩子提供这一点。我们该怎么做？所以其中的一个策略是和有孩子的邻居聚在一起，你说，好吧，每个星期六我们都要把孩子们赶出去，把你们的电子设备留在家里。我们要把你们赶出去，但他们都要出去。如果有些父母担心安全问题，我们会派一个成年人在外面只负责安全。在我看来，理想情况下，这个成年人是祖父母，因为我发现祖父母往往比父母更不容易干涉。但共识将是，那个成年人就在那里，
would be that that adult is there like a lifeguard on an ocean beach, only there in case there's some kind of real danger, but not to tell the children how to play or to solve minor problems. And so there are a few neighborhoods who have done that, including some that have actually got the city to close off the streets, if it's a busy street, during that period of time when it's playtime. And once the kids are playing together and they get to know one another, then they may find other ways to play during other times as well, other than just the formerly chosen one. Peter says schools can also play a role in promoting play.
就像海滩上的救生员一样，只有在发生某种真正的危险时才会在那儿，而不是去告诉孩子们怎么玩或者去解决小问题。所以有一些社区已经这样做了，包括一些甚至让城市在游戏时间封闭街道（如果那是一条繁忙的街道）的做法。一旦孩子们一起玩耍并且开始了解彼此，那么除了最初选择的那种方式之外，他们可能也会在其他时间找到其他玩耍的方式。彼得说学校也可以在促进游戏方面发挥作用。
He has been working with schools around the country to create play clubs. And what play club is, is an hour of free age-mixed play, usually in elementary schools, all the grades combined, so it's age 5 through 11 roughly, all combined, all playing together. Usually it is before school, but sometimes after school. And so this takes a little bit of effort on the part of the school. They have to have somebody there to manage it. And the teachers who monitor Play Club are advised, taught really, not to solve little quarrels, not to tell the children how to play better, not to worry if somebody looks unhappy. The whole purpose of play is for children to learn how to solve their own problems. For the schools that have adopted this, this has been very successful.
他一直在与全国各地的学校合作创建游戏俱乐部（play clubs）。游戏俱乐部是一小时的混合年龄自由游戏，通常在小学里，所有年级混合在一起，所以年龄大致从5岁到11岁，全部混在一起，一起玩耍。通常是在上学前，但有时也在放学后。因此，这需要学校付出一点努力。他们必须有人在那里管理。而监督游戏俱乐部的老师会得到建议，或者说真正的教导，不要去解决小争吵，不要告诉孩子们如何玩得更好，如果有人看起来不高兴也不要担心。游戏的全盘目的就是为了让孩子们学会如何自己解决问题。对于采纳了这一点的学校来说，这非常成功。
So Peter, you say that much of this boils down to a question of trust, to the willingness that adults have to trust their children, that left to their own devices, they're going to spend that time in positive and productive ways. Can you talk about this idea that at its core, there's an emotional element here, that if parents actually trusted their kids to do the smart thing and to do the right thing, they might be less interested in engaging or intervening constantly in their children's lives. Really what we're talking about here is to what degree do you as a parent feel that you need to control your child, and to what degree do you feel you can trust your child to do what is good for the child themselves without you
所以彼得，你说这在很大程度上归结为一个信任的问题，归结为成年人愿意信任他们的孩子，相信在顺其自然的情况下，他们会以积极和富有成效的方式度过这些时间。你能谈谈这个想法吗？其核心在于这里有一个情感因素，如果父母真的信任他们的孩子去做聪明的事和正确的事，他们可能会对不断参与或干涉孩子的生活不那么感兴趣。实际上我们在这里讨论的是，作为父母，你在多大程度上觉得你需要控制你的孩子，以及你在多大程度上觉得你可以信任你的孩子去做对他们自己好的事情，而不需要你
controlling. So really, ultimately, what I mean by a trustful parent is one who trusts the child's developmental processes and allows those developmental processes to occur, which really means allowing the child to play, to explore, ask questions of adults when they want to ask those questions, and all of that, to do the things that children by nature want to do. In your work you recount a remarkable story that is a kind of real-life version of the novel Lot of the Flies. The story was unearthed by a Dutch historian Rutger Bregman. Tell me that story. There was a real a real case in the 1960s of a group of schoolboys about the same age as the fictitious children in Lord of the Flies, living on a Pacific island.
去控制。所以最终，我所说的信任的父母，是指那些信任孩子的发育过程并允许这些发育过程发生的人，这实际上意味着允许孩子玩耍、探索、在想问成年人问题时向他们提问，以及所有这些，去做孩子们天生就想做的事情。在你的工作中，你讲述了一个引人入胜的故事，这是一个现实生活版的《蝇王》（Lord of the Flies）小说。这个故事是被一位荷兰历史学家鲁特格尔·布雷格曼（Rutger Bregman）发掘出来的。跟我讲讲那个故事吧。20世纪60年代确实发生过这样一个真实案例，一群校男孩的年龄和《蝇王》里的虚构儿童差不多，生活在一个太平洋岛屿上。
They ranged in age from 13 to 16, and they had decided they were tired of school. They were at a boarding school, and they called it borrowing, but they basically stole a fishing boat, and they weren't really very good sailors, so they went off into the ocean, aimed at another island that they wanted to get to.
他们的年龄从13岁到16岁不等，他们决定厌倦了学校。他们在寄宿学校，他们称之为借用，但他们基本上偷了一艘渔船，而且他们其实并不是很好的水手，所以他们出海了，目标是他们想去的另一个岛屿。
But a big storm came up and they ended up shipwrecked on an uninhabited island. And nobody found them for 15 months. Unlike in Lord of the Flies, these kids took care of themselves. They did not war with one another. They recognized, you know, our lives are in danger here. They figured out how to find food. They figured out what's edible, what's not edible. They actually planted a garden. They created a garden in case they were there for a long time. They always had one child on watch for passing ships to try to flag them.
但一场大风暴袭来，他们最终在一个无人居住的岛上遭遇海难。15个月来没有人找到他们。与《蝇王》中不同的是，这些孩子照顾了自己。他们没有互相交战。他们认识到，你知道，我们的生命在这里处于危险之中。他们想出了如何寻找食物。他们弄清楚了什么能吃，什么不能吃。他们实际上种了一个花园。如果他们在那里待很长时间，他们就开辟了一个花园。他们总是让一个孩子留守观察过往的船只，试图向它们发出信号。
One of the boys broke a leg and the kids figured out how to set the leg to protect it and it actually healed up. They took care of one another in a remarkable way. They survived. And so this is a story that's the exact opposite of the fiction, Lord of the Flies. Peter Gray is a psychologist at Boston College. He's the author of Free to Learn,
其中一个男孩断了一条腿，孩子们想出了如何固定这条腿来保护它，它居然痊愈了。他们以一种非凡的方式照顾彼此。他们活了下来。所以这是一个与小说《蝇王》截然相反的故事。彼得·格雷是波士顿学院的心理学家。他是《自由学习：
Why Unleashing the Instinct to Play will make our children happier, more self-reliant, and better students for life. Peter, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you very much for having me on. Do you have follow-up questions for Peter Gray about children, play and independence? If you'd be willing to share your question with a Hidden Brain audience,
为什么释放游戏本能会让我们的孩子更快乐、更自主、成为终身更好的学生》一书的作者。彼得，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来。你对彼得·格雷关于儿童、游戏和独立性的问题有什么后续疑问吗？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的问题，
please record a voice memo and send it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, play. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
请录制语音备忘录并将其发送至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了。那个电子邮件地址再次是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行：play。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。
We end today with a story from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. It's brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. Our story comes from River Adams, uses they them pronouns. In 1991 at the age of 19 River and their family came to the US as Jewish refugees from the Soviet Union. Though the family received a small amount of support from welfare and food stamps it wasn't nearly enough to survive on. So River and their older sister tried to apply for jobs, but neither spoke much English. For the first several months, no one would hire us because, well, we couldn't pass an
我们今天以来自我们姐妹播客《我无名英雄》（My Unsung Hero）的一个故事结束。它由T-Mobile for Business为您呈现。我们的故事来自里弗·亚当斯（River Adams），他们使用they/them代词。1991年，19岁的里弗和家人作为来自苏联的犹太难民来到美国。虽然这家人从福利和食品券那里得到了一点支持，但这远远不足以维生。因此，里弗和他们的姐姐试图申请工作，但两人都不会说太多英语。在最初的几个月里，没有人雇佣我们，因为，嗯，我们甚至无法通过一场
interview. We didn't even understand the simple questions the employers were asking. So the four of us were always hungry. Our diet consisted almost entirely of macaroni with ketchup, discounted manager's special bananas, and the cheapest cereal we could find, which was Froot Loops. But still there was never enough of these foods either. Then in the summer of 91, my sister and I were hired to work at Roy Rogers. It was a fast food chain that was very common then and they specialized in fried chicken.
面试。我们甚至听不懂雇主提出的简单问题。所以我们四个人总是饿肚子。我们的饮食几乎完全由加番茄酱的通心粉、打折的经理特价香蕉，以及我们能找到的最便宜的谷物食品——也就是Froot Loops（果味圈麦片）组成。但即使是这些食物也从来不够吃。然后在91年的夏天，我和姐姐被雇佣去罗伊·罗杰斯（Roy Rogers）工作。那是一家当时非常普遍的快餐连锁店，他们专门做炸鸡。
And the manager who hired us, he did us a kindness just by giving us the job, because we were still, you know, really not with it. And all I remember about this man is that his name was Ed. So the work was hard, but being hungry and surrounded by all this food was harder. hungry and surrounded by all this food was harder. We couldn't afford any of it. When other workers bought their meals during breaks, we didn't eat. And I think after a while,
那个雇佣我们的经理，仅仅是给我们这份工作就对我们施以了援手，因为我们当时依然，你知道的，真的很不在状态。关于这个人，我所有的记忆就是他的名字叫埃德（Ed）。所以工作很辛苦，但挨饿并且被所有这些食物包围着则更加辛苦。挨饿并被所有这些食物包围着更难。我们什么也买不起。当其他工人在休息时间买饭时，我们不吃。我想过了一段时间之后，
Ed realized the financial situation we were in, and he began to help us. We worked the evening shift. So after we would close and clean the restaurant, Ed would put the leftover fried chicken into a bucket and give it to us to take home to our family. And for the first time in months, the four of us ate, we didn't go to sleep hungry, and suddenly we had hope that we would survive. Of course we didn't understand then that Ed was breaking the rules by giving us this food. I doubt that Ed remembers us, but he is a hero in our family and we mention his name often and with utmost warmth.
埃德意识到了我们所处的财务状况，他开始帮助我们。我们上晚班。所以当我们关闭并清理完餐厅后，埃德会把剩下的炸鸡放进一个桶里，给我们让我们带回家给家人吃。几个月来，我们四个人第一次吃饱了，我们没有饿着肚子睡觉，突然间我们有了能活下去的希望。我们当时当然不明白埃德给我们这些食物是在违反规定。我怀疑埃德还记不记得我们，但他是我们家的英雄，我们经常提到他的名字，而且带着无比的温情。
I doubt he knows that these two new immigrants that he once hired and fed remember him as the first American who was kind to us. He's the man who saved us. by T-Mobile for Business. Thanks for listening. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我怀疑他是否知道，他曾经雇佣并喂饱的这两个新移民把他当作对我们好的第一个美国人来铭记。他是拯救了我们的人。由T-Mobile for Business赞助。感谢收听。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。